what is the ideal video length yeah I
mean that's a really interesting
question and like I don't mean this as a
cop-out at all but the ideal length is
as short as possible but no shorter as
long as you need for the story but no
longer because we're finding especially
now people have so many options not even
on YouTube not even on multi-format but
there's all these streaming services and
people can go outside again I mean
there's so much competition for
attention I think people can
increasingly tell if you were just doing
filler or like making a video longer
than it needs to be and the tolerance
levels for that are lower and you can
see that in your skip like little like
if people are starting to skip through
your videos or jumping through chapters
which I know is a little bit
controversial but you know some
sometimes chapters can show you where
people would have just abandoned your
video before but because they see
something interesting in a later chapter
they're willing to skip to that chapter
that's an indicator that maybe the video
is too long or not interesting enough to
get them to watch through so I think the
ideal length is what you have to explain
in as concise and interesting way uh as
dramatic a way as possible and then
don't pat it out any more than you have
to because people are going to more and
more sensitive to that on your personal
Channel where you're talking about
technology do you have a Target or is it
just random based on trying to make the
video as concise but if the story takes
a while then you'll go longer is there
any video length you personally Target
I've been testing things like recently I
went through like I went through a phase
of like my Hayden Hillier Smith phase
where I just like over edited like
everything and a little bit of like the
Mario juice like like you know Jimmy
retention editor phase where I was like
cutting everything so it'd be maximum
attention and then because I had left
less time now that I'm working at
YouTube I went through a phase where it
was like Charlie penguin Z Ludwig
mobilemail no editing like I'm just
gonna talk I'm gonna just like
extemporaneously and that's the
beautiful thing about YouTube is that we
do have like these incredibly tightly
edited like Jimmy or Eric videos where
there's not a second that hasn't been
considered and they get millions and
millions of views and then you have
Charlie and Ludwig uploading like three
times a day and the video gets a million
views I personally like to experiment I
think shorter is better that's where I'm
leading but I would encourage urge
anybody to figure out like what their
style is what Their audience Vibes with
and aim for that two things number one
I've had too much coffee today number
two if you have not seen our free master
class yet you're gonna love it if you're
serious about growing your YouTube
channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class